FIRST, THE COMING BIDEN LOCK
DOWN.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF THE ANGLE.
THE OLD SAYING NO NEWS IS GOOD
NEWS?
WHERE COVID IS CONCERNED, WHY
DOES IT ALWAYS SEEM LIKE GOOD
NEWS IS BAD NEWS?
JUST AS THE INGRAHAM ANGLE TOLD
YOU MONTHS AGO, BIDEN HAS TWO
RUNNING MATES.
THERE’S KAMALA.
WE KNOW ABOUT HER.
AND THEN THERE’S COVID.
THE MORE ACTIVE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THEY BOTH ARE, THE LESS
OLD JOE HAS TO CAMPAIGN FOR
HIMSELF.
NOW, THE PROBLEM FOR THE BIDEN
COVID TICKET IS THAT THE VIRUS
IS SLOWING DOWN JUST LIKE THE
PRESIDENTIAL NOMINEE HIMSELF.
COME ON, MAN.
THE LAST TWO WEEKS, THE AVERAGE
NUMBER OF DAILY COVID CASES HAS
PLUMMETED 17%.
REMEMBER WHEN WE WERE FIRST SOLD
THE LOCKDOWN, IT WAS ALL ABOUT
SAVING THE HOSPITALS.
IT WAS VERY IMPORTANT TO DO
THAT.
CHECK OUT THE LATEST DATA ON
COVID HOSPITALIZATIONS BY AGE
GROUP FROM THE CDC.
IT’S DOWN, DOWN, DOWN.
AMONG ALL AGE GROUPS.
THE HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DEATHS
IN ARIZONA, IN TEXAS AND IN
FLORIDA ALSO CONTINUE TO DECLINE
SHARPLY.
THIS IS ALL GOOD NEWS.
>> WE CONTINUE TO MAKE PROGRESS
IN OUR FIGHT AGAINST THE CHINA
VIRUS.
NEW WEEKLY CASES HAVE DECLINED
BY 44% SINCE JULY.
DEATHS DECLINED BY 20% COMPARED
TO JUST LAST WEEK.
IT’S GOING DOWN VERY RAPIDLY.
>> Laura: OF COURSE, DR. FAUCI
COULD NOT LET AN UPBEAT VIEW GO
WITHOUT CRITIQUE.
>> I HAVE TO DISAGREE WITH THAT.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT YOU JUST
MENTIONED, THE STATISTICS,
THEY’RE DISTURBING.
WE’RE PLATEAUING AT AROUND
40,000 CASES A DAY.
THE DEATHS ARE AROUND 1,000.
>> Laura: OKAY, AGAIN, WE DON’T
KNOW HOW MANY OF THE 1,000
PEOPLE DIED FROM COVID OR WITH
COVID.
DR. FAUCI DIDN’T ELABORATE ON
THAT.
HE DID DROP THIS BOMB SHELL.
>> IF YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT
GETTING BACK TO A DEGREE OF
NORMALITY, WHICH RESEMBLES WHERE
WE WERE PRIOR TO COVID, IT’S
WELL INTO 2021.
MAYBE EVEN TOWARDS THE END OF
2021.
>> Laura: OKAY.
LET ME TRANSLATE THAT FOR YOU.
IF BIDEN WINS, YOU’RE GOING TO
BE LOCKED DOWN ON AND OFF FOR
MOST OF THE NEXT YEAR PLUS.
NOW, WHEN BIDEN SAYS HE’S GOING
TO LISTEN TO THE DOCTORS, IT’S
NOT DR. JUST FAUCI.
HE MEANS MICHAEL OSTERHOLM WHO
CO AUTHORED A PIECE THAT SAID
THAT WE COMMIT TO A MORE
RESTRICTIVE LOCK DOWNSTATE BY
STATE FOR UP TO SIX WEEKS THE
CRUSH THE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS.
OKAY.
THE ASSUMPTION BEING THAT DOING
SO WOULD STOP THE VIRUS.
HUH.
THE DOCTOR IS A LIKELY CANDIDATE
FOR A TOP JOB IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
HE GENUINELY SEEMS TO DESPISE
RED STATE AMERICA WHERE PEOPLE
HAVE JUST DECIDED, YOU KNOW, WE
UNDERSTAND THE RISK BUT WE HAVE
TO MOVE ON WITH OUR LIVES.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
IN KENTUCKY, AND LOTS OF OTHER
STATES, THEY’RE NOW PLAYING HIGH
SCHOOL FOOTBALL AND OTHER
SPORTS.
IN TEXAS, THEY’RE GOING TO
IN-PERSON SCHOOL FIVE DAYS A
WEEK.
IN TENNESSEE, PEOPLE ARE
SCHEDULING WEDDINGS AGAIN.
IN NEBRASKA, THEY’RE NOW IN
STAGE 4 MEANING IT’S BACK TO
NORMAL.
KIDS ARE IN SCHOOL AND LEARNING.
AND THAT MEANS -- THE MEDIA HAS
TO PUSH THE PANIC 24/7 ALL THE
MORE ESPECIALLY ABOUT SCHOOLS.
LOOK AT THE HEADLINES.
HOW ABOUT THE TEACHERS?
EVERY LOSS OF LIFE IS HORRIBLE.
BUT AS MANY INCLUDING "THE
WASHINGTON EXAMINER" POINTED OUT
WHAT THESE STORIES HAVE IN
COMMON, THERE’S NO EVIDENCE THAT
ANY OF THE TEACHERS MENTIONED
CONTRACTED THE VIRUS WHILE
TEACHING.
IF ANY ONE THING DRIVES THE LEFT
OFF THE LEDGE, AN INDOOR TRUMP
RALLY WHERE PEOPLE ARE HAVING
FUN LIKE LAST NIGHT IN NEVADA.
>> THE EVENT WAS IN DEFIANCE OF
STATE LEADERSHIP.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE HAS A CALLOUS
DISREGARD FOR HUMAN LIFE.
>> IT WAS AN ANTI SCIENCE RALLY
IN NEVADA.
>> Laura: AS USUAL, THEY’RE ALL
SUPER SPREADERS OF HYPOCRISY.
ALWAYS COMPLAINING ABOUT WHAT
REGULAR AMERICANS ARE DOING TO
TRY TO GO ON AND LIVE NORMAL
LIVES.
YOU KNOW, THE PURSUIT OF
HAPPINESS THING.
BUT THEY NEVER COMPLAIN, NONE OF
THEM, WHEN HOARDS OF LOOTERS
RACE INTO STORES, SMASH THROUGH
CITIES AND DO WHATEVER THEY WANT
WHENEVER THEY WANT TO.
WHEN THEY’RE IN A DESPERATE NEED
OF A BLOW-OUT, OF COURSE, MASK
OPTIONAL, OF COURSE.
WELL, ALTHOUGH GOVERNORS FROM
FLORIDA TO SOUTH DAKOTA
RECOGNIZE THAT COVID IS A
HORRIBLE TRAGEDY AND THAT MANY
MIGHT STILL DIE FROM IT, THEY
HAVE TAKEN SHUT DOWNS OFF THE
TABLE.
THEY HAVE DONE THAT BECAUSE THE
SOCIETAL COST TO DAILY LIFE, TO
EVERYTHING ABOUT THE LIVES WE
LEAD IS JUST TOO HIGH.
FIRST, LOCKDOWNS DON’T WORK.
JUST LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF CASES
RISING IN EUROPE IF YOU THINK
THEY DO WORK.
SECOND, THE DAMAGE THAT THEY
CAUSE IS CATASTROPHIC TO OUR
ECONOMY, OUR CHILDREN’S
EDUCATION.
WE’RE ALL SEEING THAT.
MENTAL HEALTH AND OUR SAFETY.
BY THE WAY, THEY’RE ALSO
ILLEGAL.
TODAY A FEDERAL DISTRICT JUDGE
IN PENNSYLVANIA ISSUED A
STINGING 66-PAGE REBUKE STRIKING
DOWN GOVERNOR TOM WOLF’S
EMERGENCY COVID MEASURES CITING
MULTIPLE CONSTITUTIONAL
VIOLATIONS.
VIOLATED THE FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHT OF ASSEMBLY, THE DUE
PROCESS CLAUSE AND THE 14th
AMENDMENT.
JUDGE WILLIAM STRIKEMAN SAID THE
RESPONSE TO A PANDEMIC CANNOT BE
PERMITTED TO UNDERMINE THE
SYSTEM OF CHECKS AND BALANCES.
HERE DEFENDANTS ARE PERMITTED TO
ACT WITH LITTLE IF ANY INPUT
FROM THE LEGISLATURE.
THE CONSTITUTION CANNOT ACCEPT
THE CONCEPT OF A NEW NORMAL WITH
THE BASIC LIBERTIES OF THE
PEOPLE CAN BE OPEN-ENDED
MITIGATION MEASURES.
IT WAS A PHENOMENAL RULING.
WE’VE BEEN TELLING YOU THIS FOR
MONTHS.
OUR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS MAY
NOT BE INDEFINITELY ABRIDGED BY
EXECUTIVE FIAT, PERIOD.
I EXPECT SIMILAR CHALLENGES TO
BE LAUNCHED IN OTHER BLUE STATES
BY BUSINESSES, PARENTS, SCHOOLS
AND CHURCHES WHO ARE FED UP WITH
BEING SHUT DOWN.
BUT REMEMBER, FOR BIDEN’S TEAM,
IT WILL NEVER BE THE RIGHT TIME
TO RETURN POWER TO THE PEOPLE.
SO I THINK OF IT THIS WAY.
IF YOU WANT TO SEE YOUR
GRANDPARENTS NEXT YEAR, IF YOU
WANT YOUR SON TO HAVE AN ACTUAL
GRADUATION CEREMONY, IF YOU’RE A
COLLEGE STUDENT AND YOU WANT TO
BE ON CAMPUS, IF YOU WANT TO
WATCH MARCH MADNESS OR WANT TO
GO TO EASTER SUNDAY SERVICES,
YOU SHOULD NOT VOTE FOR BIDEN.
BECAUSE IF HE WINS, NONE OF THAT
IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
NOT EVEN IN RED STATES.
THE DOCTORS WILL ALWAYS TELL HIM
IT’S NOT SAFE UNTIL WE HAVE AN
EFFECTIVE VACCINE THAT HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFULLY ADMINISTERED TO
MOST AMERICANS WHETHER WE WANT
IT OR NOT.
THE CONSEQUENCES WILL BE
DISASTROUS.
MILLIONS OF JOBS WILL BE
PERMANENTLY LOST AND ALL OF
AMERICA WILL START LOOKING LIKE
NEW YORK AND CALIFORNIA, ROLLING
BLACKOUTS, ROLLING RIOTERS AND
BLM RADICALS HAVE THE RUN OF THE
STREETS UNCHECKED AND
UNCHALLENGED.
THE CHOICE IN NOVEMBER DAY BY
DAY COULD NOT BE CLEARER.
LIBERTY OR LOCKDOWN.
STRENGTH OR SUBMISSION.